patents that was weird hold on I don't
see why don't see any microphone what
you call the dog let me sit not seeing
any feedback from the audio always
something let me know it says we live
going live so let me know if ya see it
come back yeah this is real all right
seeing level we got to make sure they
hear it cuz I'm not getting okay you I'm
gonna mute the tab all of ya
all right we made it they said it gets a
we back you can hear me but can ya hear
King King ahead alright I don't know
what's going all the way for a second
why they say they they say as hopefully
everybody can filter out put the tweets
back out sorry about that yeah I don't
know what's going on the SSD took y'all
out anyway consider can see the price
people ain't blaming me for that because
the last time something like that well
this is straight YouTube and we were
chilling Cristobal only the Saudis
decided I could continue down all right
so back to us say it adding we got to
get solve it I mean actually we got to
get a lot more you know how much they
heard of that make a short I understand
why they're doing it from a business
standpoint this is one of those state of
things that has has to be done because
they're looking at like the Ellie
collector's editions they don't know if
they can get that ever there they're
looking at from the standpoint of
digital they don't know if they can get
the physical units out they don't know I
think if the collector's edition because
there's a lot of stuff that comes in
these editions but I don't know if they
can get that and I have a feeling that
they fear that people would cancel the
le editions that they bought a digital
copy of it which i think is kind of
ridiculous but anyway you know what I
really in to to that point I understand
on there but to me as as you know I'm
not particularly a fan of a lot of stuff
aside enjoy the game but I'm not a huge
fan but there's a lot of people that had
emotional breakdown meltdown that this
game got delayed again and I feel like
even if you did just make an only
digital release
you get this physical stuff took in care
of right I don't think it would impact
the cells dramatically because I feel
like last of us too isn't a league of
its own
let's be really it's in a league of its
own this game's gonna so extremely well
regardless
shut up to a Jonathan be here either
quite he said filed a super chat
delaying games due to physical copies
what is this 1997 are they gonna send
the demo discs out in the next month
PlayStation underground magazines good
to you I just felt like this game is
gonna stop regardless what they do in to
delay because of physical things I don't
think something Sony would actually do I
really I think there's something to
happen here they have they didn't do
that they did do that fur and they did
one charge for what they do it was like
a week week and a half
mmm they delayed it for cuz and that's
Beck's game sold like gangbusters I mean
no I mean
and maybe but maybe part of it was so
anyways nobody knows closer to this
t-virus thing than any of us you were
the first to pull out of packs there
right like maybe it's it might be
hitting one of their teams like harder I
don't know what it is about hit Japan I
think Japan is one of the worst places
in the world right now with it so you
know we'll have to see it's like I said
I understand why they're doing it but
from a fan standpoint I know their fans
are disappointed and I feel like there's
got to be a middle ground that they can
meet especially right now with the team
buyers going on
you know I think this game would sell
well well because no one got to play
look okay let's get look appear you're
making some good points you feel that
Sony is in tune more into what's going
on what's your thoughts on this whole
laughs yeah I mean I don't know man I I
think it I think that the problem that
they're probably facing is that this
game is going to be a juggernaut they're
watching pre pre-orders and they're
probably through the round they're just
not able to yeah I mean yeah I mean
maybe the network is well imagine you've
said last of us right now is up for
pre-order it would probably crash the
internet yeah which is good yeah good
game is the game is gonna be big the
only other thing that this is where I
put on my like my especially as an Xbox
fan what about the Jason Schreyer
article yes I know them reports about
like what is going on at Naughty Dog and
some of these bigger studios and then
with people being forced to work from
home
mm-hmm yeah like what if there's
something what if there's something
there maybe like I give them the benefit
of the doubt I think it's earned because
it's quality studio and they've had this
before where they want to make sure that
they were actually able to manufacture
enough hard copies for it to go off
that's a thing that has happened before
so I get it
right but like what is the like how are
they doing how is the health of the
studio and the people who work there and
now have a completely different they say
they're at the one-yard line
right I mean games on that until games
done and even then you still have day
one patches and everything right I mean
what a corpsman Anil like I said in that
PlayStation podcast he he try to get out
of not saying man lying I'm gonna try to
repeat what he said you just say it kind
of like the culture was like hey if you
guys need to take care of your families
and do whatever do that like like it
didn't seem urgent from a game
development stand but based on the
energy he was giving off right Pete the
vibe I'm getting I'm just gonna jump in
right now cuz I guess something is that
everything seems to be around global
distribution right the vibe I'm getting
is they want this thing to be out at the
same time globally and not limit certain
subsections and then also other people's
internet countries internet connections
and we all know let's be real you know
PlayStation Network right now they've
already started to throttle it as a
result of you know the virus or whatever
so to me this just seems like this is
about money I'm gonna keep it a buck
what it feels to me it feels like they
are trying to maximize this is their
juggernaut game they are trying to
maximize the most exposure as possible
and I don't think they feel comfortable
doing this segmented kind of a release
and thus this may even be Sony you know
say it from coming from up top
saying hey easy now until this thing
gets resolved until we get this retail
situation resolved maybe that's it but
let's get solve it in K I think it's
those collector's editions you guys
basically hit the nail on the head like
I think it's just for them Sony if you
look at Tony and and their approach to
to physical copies and stuff like that
that stuff that's still their bread and
butter like that in a way that it isn't
for Microsoft anymore right would you
pass that's not what their touting hey
it's a different thing so for Sony is
it's a matter of how do we get this
physical stuff out at the same
digital stuff in ink and then at the
same time he talking about like yeah the
bandwidth stuff is an issue especially
now where everybody's online all over
the world people will issue just just
interrupt you real quick so do you think
that one of the biggest reasons they
don't want cuz I don't think that
they're not completely against the
digital thing you know the Lord Cognito
said earlier the you know Trotman said
that they're not do you think one of the
reasons that are not wanting to do that
is because they're scared it might bring
down PSN and they won't be able to he
mentioned it literally that he literally
mentioned it specifically on the
PlayStation podcast literally what you
said their concern is again region
network connectivity and launching at
the same time they don't want to make it
unfair but they are considering it they
still consider heated he didn't give the
vibe like undef initely it could still
go you know real long they just tryna it
seems like a logistic issue that's the
vibe I got could do you something yeah I
said logistic side to me that's what it
is like you said it's that big banger it
is their game of the generation they
don't want to they don't want to
shortchange it in the in any way shape
or form and doing that right now which
or change it so my guess is they they
have a plan in place for the moment
everything subsides and and the economy
sort of opens up again and they're gonna
figure out how to do that but for me
they're gonna hold on to it otherwise
because you can't logistically you just
cannot get the game to everybody in the
way that you want to and if it was if it
was a second-tier game you know maybe
they'd consider just doing that and
getting it out there just because like a
haddock said like people want to play
lady people have nothing but time on the
hands right right this is different
though I think any chance that that the
launch of this game could be somewhat
smeared by anything outside of their
control they're not gonna put they're
not gonna risk that happening right they
want a little control of the messaging
around this game I agree
I think this you know I think that it's
a little bit of everything I think that
the t-virus is the final processes of
you know making sure the game comes out
bug free I think it has to do with the
production I think it's more of
everything than just one of everyone
one hold on your boy judge did we get
the super chat from did we get the yeah
we got that we gotta find all this super
trap for Jonathan b-roll reason for the
delay I hear Jim Ryan was easy stuff
King do you wanna go we read that one we
got that one okay just just to be on the
safe side
you gotta find all the super child for
him Jonathan be delaying games due to
physical copies what is it this 1997 are
they gonna suck cities demo do something
PlayStation underground magazine - when
you reread that twice in case you didn't
read them yeah so PO all right so that's
that I sat back and I you know this this
is the sucky part it's real quick before
you go we gotta draw a super trap from
stitch we'll buy more services and what
my magic loud continue okay so this is
what sucks like going last because you
hear everybody's stuff but it is the
benefit as well right so at first I
would like to say everybody is onto
something let's let's get onto something
there right when the sums like let's get
that right so I tackled this question in
Twitter and I also tackle this question
on a PTM blam show lamp shop so um very
good show yes
I encourage out to go check out his
podcast mm-hmm all right so I'm
listening to you guys and I've been also
attacking this question on Twitter now
let me start off by saying first and
foremost I was purchasing in this game
because what is it it's the three to
four year PlayStation triple a bang
every time every time I say yes that's
beautiful yes lot of Provocateur talking
to you so a lot of you Sony frauds out
there that we're gonna body cam and you
know you're fake with the fake outrage
you oh it's
II wasn't buying in any way shut up oh
but I was mm-hmm
I was gonna buy this shout-out to BG I
was gonna buy this half-baked game that
I raved about that didn't have the
multiplayer Lord right so shout out to
BG again for bringing this to light
because he's he's not he's not taking a
boot off your neck right
shoutout to BG again he's bringing this
one piece of topic up that I really
encourage everyone to watch that yeah
hilarious hilarious video be Jesus bad
actually agree with right so I think
isn't there's multiple angles here but I
want you guys to also remember this is
different Sony's his budget Sony mmm-hmm
I had big ball of Sony but the
carnivorous virus has it on your wallet
so d monetize my YouTube version of the
of the day continue we go
and also this is where sovereigns point
is true sovereigns point is they
antiquated in the delivery system and
you're stuck in the mud and you're not
flexible think he'll explain that he was
a child with things agility is agility
stats are high yes we got yeah yeah he's
cat-like quickness out of control
continue you see when you when you're
inflexible you might break right so they
decide just the whole lawn financially
we can't risk this money we need this
because we are still operating off of
the whole old business model mm-hmm
right where we don't have a system in
that is flexible and agile enough for us
to motivate in these new times right now
they said something about the antenna on
there and might not be able to hold up
to the games being purchased with images
we know 101 percent of your community
purchases games anyway so that is 20
million not one game sold 120 million so
let's get back to what I'm talking about
me all right let's get back to what I'm
talking about how I told you that money
was looking funny in a light and now
that just seemed that somebody's putting
a spotlight on them a the game that's
supposed to emanate generation they
pushed the back because why you haven't
seen any games from PlayStation 5 yet so
is it is it the tension he said
something about a 10-4 I'm going
terraform right now okay oh maybe this
game is pushed back so it can get closer
to the PlayStation 5 launch that's what
I was thinking that's coming like I'm in
next year anyway so no that's not it
financially maybe attic is right right
maybe they need to make sure that they
sell all those are copies not I got out
like I could agree me a property but but
i'mma tell you this as a statue
collective ooh
we wait years right
we don't care and so if I'm gonna get it
digitally I'm not gonna cancel my little
big-ticket item right eat a little halo
head up there right and so I got the
game I got the game digitally anyway so
but I still got it
so I don't believe that's a factor hmm I
believe actually there's other things
going on cuz maybe like ya'll said Sony
has been on the forefront of this
carnivorous virus for a minute right and
they've been pulling out of pack saving
money pulling out all those hundred
shows that never will transpire oh my
god their game
now this money is being saved now they
need this game to be a success I believe
so later you try great I believe that
they needed to but the millions to 30
million um but I do also believe that
this is Sony catering to the corporate
entity and not to the fanbase now this
will you take that stick off the box
only for fans because you're not for the
fans my man oh you're not for the fans
you haven't been for the fans for a long
time all right um
shout out to Jim Wright a lot of things
wouldn't happen with old Sony mmm you
know Oh Sony is bold oh Sonia's brash oh
so he's the big balls that walk in the
room you know who they are this new Sony
comes in the back door you don't know
he's there there's new Sony and as quiet
as a church mouse oh [ __ ] yes
giving you red flag after red flag after
red flag T's gonna stand up and say who
is this dude he's messing around and
daddy's close but is he really
delivering what he wants to deliver he's
not him the game that you want and you
know if you can get it digitally right
but you're not getting it digitally why
because corporate entities will say this
right we have business plans in place
brother you're gonna have to meet these
goals may be right that has to go to
Walmart maybe it has to go to other
stores and maybe to these Best Buy's so
they can sell their copies so they can
do this I don't believe that is customer
and consumer friendly boom but I believe
it it's corporate friendly right so here
this in this new time mm-hmm Sony will
wait until the delivery system caters to
the corporate entity right that is
holding their hand cuz when really they
can't take this loss when are you
talking most mostly about like the
distribution of it I you just made me
realize maybe it's about on that whole
like the dollar side maybe it's because
not know games are being sold physical
now you cuz you can't go to a store to
buy though that's a bumper that's less
so maybe it's not the distribution I
think is part of it obviously but the
fact is so they're waiting for this
whole thing to like to double weighs
exactly go into a water advise I got in
the slowest horse you're like I
literally said that mm-hmm
that's part of when it comes to to
especially their big releases right
I'm they've been touting this last of a
special edition and it's been on
pre-order for god knows how long so
that's huge for them and they know that
the fans of their type of games are
always going to be expecting some sort
of things like like that especially for
their biggest games so that that's it
that's it's huge I would assume and this
is just me assuming that the vast
majority of day one sales on the
PlayStation side do come from people who
buy those types of editions the biggest
fan that's what I said I think I think a
lot of its those I think they know that
they fear that when it comes to stuff
like that now I don't think that that
makes a huge portion of the money but I
do think that brings in a law all right
we have to admit the right retail is
still very important oh it is yeah I do
think I do think they would take a hit a
little bit in terms of financially but I
think for the most part people gonna buy
this in the first month they're not
going to wait for that physical version
that's gone by digitally and I think
that's that's one of the fears they have
they know people are gonna I don't know
man I guess you okay you look a Gamestop
and they're like they're willing to tell
the government no we're essential and
because of how big a physical sale that
they got off of I just say and do that
they know I think we I think it's silly
for us to underestimate how much sales
happen at retail I don't think no one's
under estimating the physical portion I
think everyone really understands that
they would take a little bit of
financial or physical there I think
their fear is these physical copies are
going to end up buying a digital when
it's gonna consistently down PSN and
that's the reason they're not want out
of it that's no way there's
you're having people that are getting
just the physical copy just just getting
digital you're gonna literally have
people constantly downloading this game
inputting PS and down it's definitely
not gonna break your network that should
be game don't give me a break what won
the Final Fantasy 7 demo came out PSN
went down for a short time mmm 7 demo
right imagine I mean we can't really
talk his xbox lies were down like use
any same server since PlayStation 2 so
they just woke up and they just got you
know Microsoft's help with this thing
you know no think maybe they're afraid
to film I hit the switch no I just think
I think there's been G sales is somebody
everybody should be following on Twitter
and he was talking a lot about like the
split of Doom and Animal Crossing
everything it even if works all the way
to the point where the split is like
even seventy I don't think we're here
yet but seventy percent our digital
sales 30 percent or retail of course
that's a massive like skew over to
digital yeah if you take that 30 percent
that you're kind of counting on and
that's down 90 percent mm-hmm then yes
delay it indefinitely I actually think
that makes the most sense out of
anything I've ever heard I don't think I
don't think the internet going down or
their servers going down from buying a
game because you're all buying baby
you're all no matter what if you if you
download if you download the game
completely digital or if you buy a
physical you're downloading a day one
patch it's gonna have this it's gonna
have a tremendous impact day one no
matter what I totally think this is
about how do we make sure as many people
can buy this game as possible yeah I
think that if Neil druckmann
is on a podcast saying that this is one
of their concerns but they're still
considering a digital edition this is
definitely one of their concerns is
because if you tell people like look you
can't do physical right now but you can
still do digital I do I have a hundred
percent thought process that PSN would
have a lot of issues handling that
traffic and I think that that is one of
their concerns it's not what the biggest
concern but no way I think that would
happen I mean no
if you have millions of people going to
a black download is alone at the same
time it's going to constantly go down
I'm not saying that your join is wrong
I'm saying that this validity in there
because we've seen it manifests itself
anywhere I'm not saying at that part I'm
just saying that is there's a lot of
angles to this one little story right
and I believe that everybody is right in
their own manner I believe it makes one
big pitches a collage and I do honestly
believe I don't care and I think is more
like 40 to 50 percent in physical copies
brand sold and then and I honestly
believe Sony is at a point financially
that that is not an option you know
though they can't do that also believe
that there is considerations to the
corporate entities that need to
distribute these games I mean I believe
that they need to have a friendly
relationship going into a hardware and
system battle going forward that they
don't lose shelf space to another
company that's battling them for shelf
space later on by angering they pop
their partners I think Oprah partners I
think if you get technical I think it
would be fair to say that everything we
said is is the thing that they've been
looking at and because of all these
issues because of you know they have
issues you know maybe facility well
their attic they had issues with the
physical David issues at the collector's
edition that I think if it was just one
of these it would be delighted as a
multi TIFF it was just one of these they
wouldn't delay the game indefinitely
because of all of these they have to
delay the game and not give it a release
day because they don't know how to fix
all these issues because the worlds on
fire I mean the counter the counter to
my own argument is actually that
spending on gaming is up over all right
now it's a one industry that's actually
working out right now that's that it
seems to be doing okay so there there
might be the argument to say launch now
like launch as soon as possible get
these games out when you can cuz people
are spending money steam is setting
records on a daily basis are concurrent
users so there is there's appetite on
that front that's one of the things that
kind of make me want to lean towards you
know the game might really not might not
be done I do feel like as of right now
look at Animal Crossing I'm not saying
I'm across and got these cells because
we're in quarantine where the t-virus is
making
people stay in so people are playing
games I'm saying that the harcore gonna
buy this game regardless digital and it
is done they say no they did say in the
game right now then why can't they do
because it's the biggest game you see
the mess that Square Enix is but it is a
mess but they're still getting it done
by a look how disjointed in mangled it's
looking with some ranges don't have it
in some if it was strictly just physical
so like I said it's it's it's a thing of
all it's not just one it's definitely
because the game is not part of me feels
like you know wants to lean towards just
because it's the perfect time to release
game did I not say that game but okay
this this is one point this isn't the
square Enix and Sony is two different
things right Square X is a third-party
company and it can put the game out
whenever they choose and whatever right
but Sony this is Sony's money game buddy
generation is building up to this has
been what was like last shown at the e3
this this game is going to frame they
exit into but see again shout out to be
Jean this game because I'm I can't I
can't reference it enough if y'all
didn't get it yet one hundred and fifty
hundred and sixty that's watching if
y'all didn't get in enough shout out the
BG
does this game set up more delays let me
get these super jump yeah um do we get
stitched with two hours with the wheel
by boys your service that well Bob
there's been another one we missed a
couple
we got gaming for teh fire on a super
check game stop should be celebrating
Sony by making this statement are
telling gamers the importance of
physical media just food for thought
shout to Victor anestine mm which I
shout to the best podcast online book of
ex salute we got forte again to uh super
chat my store has 238 pre-orders and 64
collector's editions salute
shout out to Sifl poetic ex initiative -
awesome job we forgetting the
multiplayer why not put it in well let
me let me handle Carl sure all I got you
two dollars Super Junior why hasn't
Disney released Black Widow then there's
a difference between the actual theatres
media and video game media you can't
really go out and do a digital event
with with with gaming and have the same
result that you can with the movie
theater so we have to have you back off
running way low listen at the end of the
day I hear all your points
I agree for the most part and all the
stuff is a fact I was agreeing with our
guests that this would be a good time so
that's why I kind of do lean a little
bit towards that that theory and I also
says are you ready to go there it's
everything together and not just one or
the other okay so you flip-flopping
anyway like I was one foot in one for
that okay cool
all I'm saying is look the virus is real
good the virus is real all right
all I'm saying is oh this expected I
agree with Jay subscribe expect more of
this from the game industry we've
already seen wasteland you
we've already seen minecraft dungeon
like I said get ready software is where
this thing is here not everyone is
equipped to work remotely from home and
we made probably the majority of
students aren't right and then the
distribution aspect that is a big loss
that a lot of companies are not willing
to take and some of them will hold off
until this thing kind of blows over we
get more clarity on what's going on in
the world that's all I'm saying
still with this time to continue we
gotta like really just end it like we
did we get all these other super tests
we got Forte with the my store has 200
300 okay we got Charles Paul and we got
we gotta get stitch again - awesome chat
slowly pushing back because they have no
game for PlayStation okay just real
quickly just run through that stuff yeah
we got well we got all the next-gen so
um oh man dax with the - ah so much i
didn't say anything that's what's going
on I understand what you're gonna say
you'd love to say Sony's on fire so
we've got a dick this is you with
concerns you know PS 5 there's been some
articles and there's been a little bit
of chat which you know nothing's been
confirmed let me just say that but there
is little rumors going around a little
concern coming from some of the fans not
everyone that you know PS 5 you know in
the words of conky Lord key it's
unstable so you know I do want to
briefly go over this because we're going
way too long so you know I mean we think
about the unstable we got it was giving
you the layout I said oh then I'm
overclocked everything then I hit the
ceiling so remember when we got the
information early on that they was
having problems with the cooling that
this isn't never read know how the
problem
you didn't that was until mark Cerny
came around told you we could over
collect everything we popped it on here
like people don't like you know I've
been PC gaming a little bit I've
overclocked stuff it does raise
temperature like dramatic person okay
they're coming out and saying that
they're ten point three or ten point six
but they're really nine point two that
might be some rows of truth in them
listen here listen right so do you know
this is the whole my developers in the
rooms
listen all to all my PC heads anytime
that y'all win and y'all overclock GPU
right but your CP was pretty funny did
you a boost that you boosted you boosted
GPU you boost your you CPU what happen
to your PC either you're caught fire if
you didn't have proper cooling or just
turned off right off and it just apply
I've actually had to replace a fan
because it just turns off right yeah
right so you just let that blue screen
you had a critical error that happened
at your joint right so how many chips is
failing with this overclocking in this
critical error but also remember they
were trying to lower the cost on the
cooling system that they was having
right so to to actually get the
PlayStation 5 in order to you know for a
good price range because they they had a
fixed price where this goes back to
field dominance max mrs. they are agile
enough and they showed you how they have
the the vapor cooling chamber and he
also have this gigantic huge fan at the
top of the joint right so they let you
see their cooler solution and how the
tower design is made all right so this
one leads me to believe that the
PlayStation is gonna probably have an
hour design as well um but also they're
having problems with the coolant now
would they have to because you have to
juggle memory it's the juggling systems
the unstable box
no it's like this is like a teetering
board all right do you either easy all
the way here are you all the way there
and you have to pull from here to get to
there so let's say right now right they
throttle it back they actually put it to
the real specs at a 9.2 hey you know
let's just let's just say cooler heads
prevail right bring it back to the 9.2
and is actually a stable box now and
cooling issues actually under control
what I'm thinking is and I really
believe this is true issues we might
have a super red ring of death going on
with this box just be on X boxes of you
got to put it above and beyond because
we didn't have information going into
the X boxes that there was filming at
the rate that they were and I brought
three or four 360s trust me all right
there you know it happened to me I saw
it I was like oh no um and I and I'm
hearing about it early so they prepared
in your wallet and you're gonna buy this
thing four times well but is it is it
the problem right now is do they have a
good cooler solution or should they
throttle it back and I really believe
that they're so set in stone is still
afraid of the power narrative the
throttle lip right now will destroy them
for marketing because they see it a
squeeze it all the way up to ten point
something and get over the hurdle and
they trying to tell you that the two
teraflops ain't really that bad but if
you really looked at it and it was more
like four teraflops oh right then that
becomes a bigger problem so is it that
they they overclocked it and is burning
up is it true to these thing or it's the
form factor and it looks like the dev
kits with a thousand fans on it looks
like a vacuum cleaner or they do what
Xbox had done prior to the S which was
they take the big power u and they put
it out there you got a big power block
on it look like it has a piece of form
factor I think in fact there's a big
thing because you showed it to us yeah
hold on a second
they haven't showed it to us yet and if
you think about okay cerny is the
architect of it right but Sony is a
Japanese company and
the design ethos of Japanese companies
is small like if they just go small I do
not think that in any way shape or form
they were ever ever gonna make a council
that looks like the Xbox series acts no
before they were always going to make it
smaller right is when you look at the
dev kits right it's like why does it
look so weird well they need to figure
out you know how to get cooling in there
right they need to figure out how to get
all that hot air out out of there so to
me yeah despite the fact that this this
rumor it stuff comes from you know
whatever Microsoft source or whatever
the case might be that does worry me the
fact that we haven't seen the form fact
of the machine because like I said like
that Japanese design ethos pushes
smaller right so how do you get how do
you get that type of performance out of
a small box and and this you know that
the 1x showed us that you can do it
right but this is this is still this is
exponentially stronger than there so let
me switch and then get low capri living
flame to our super chat they running hot
because they didn't clock the SSD okay
phase 2000 ever see face in a minute 23
became my Sony about to show y'all why
the Kings they the kings of console
gaming every PlayStation system one a
generation except for ps3 so he's out
here you got to let you know yeah banjo
all right let's get your agree on what
you think sorry about this cooling the
rumors issues is it hi busy all these
sources really you or where you at with
these rumors I'm trying to sign like
where to land really on this on the show
because like part of me is just like I'm
mostly like pretty down local down the
middle but it is fun to just kind of
like slam a little bit yes yeah like
PlayStation is like a massively like if
it's a beat on this show is you know
next last week I could be on Sony side
this week I could be on Xbox Live next
week I could be on the Tendo side you'll
never know yeah I I think I'm I think
King was talking about like there's
there's been a lot of red flags there's
been a lot of benefit of the doubt
extended to Sonia but also like
well-deserved 100 million consoles like
really two out of four you
when you think about it is actually
really remarkable so I don't know I
don't know I have not like that none of
us know but we do know that we haven't
seen a form factor we've seen the dev
kits that look kind of strange um
they're being kind of cagey about some
stuff now some now I mean it's not the
easiest time to be launching a system
that I think Phil Spencer was talking
about that as well
who knows dude who knows but price form
form factor could be a massive part of
this in terms of getting the cooling
system but I've been there I bought a I
bought a computer secondhand at one
point in my life and the guy had
everything overclocked and around like
garbage like it absolutely ran like
trash to the point where I just I just
don't do it anymore I would rather have
it stable then then try and squeeze
every bit out of it and the final thing
that I would say about it is you know
when when consoles reach the end of
their lifetime that's when you start to
like squeeze every ounce out of the
thing like the Xbox really has gone
through a journey do you really want to
start the console generation like like
sprinting like this is a yeah pace
yourself a little bit right right so to
your point
you're on kind of kingside that you're
concerned with this the variable clock
tech as far as to start a generation
with that you sounds like a bad idea to
me but I don't know anything about
making games or systems but I wouldn't I
just want to point this out real quick
do you think it's possible like I don't
know this is something that happened but
do you think it's possible that Sony had
these I do specs 9.2 but then when they
dropped that that series and they got
the rumors they're like yo what can you
do like okay let's try to overclock see
what happens yo it's it's overheating
right and they're doing a redesign to
try to accommodate for that overclocked
design do you think that might be a
possibility of what's going on here I
mean who knows I mean obviously it's all
speculation that almost everything is
speculating spec we have a lot of super
chance yeah could you get the soup chat
sir what's the last one that we got did
we get the living flame right or running
yeah we got that so we gotta find all
the super champ from face to face you
gotta get Jonathan we got a $5 super
trap from Jonathan B I love reading his
so forget the games what are y'all gonna
cook audiences
you know there's a train right now on
tik-tok about people cooking stuff on
the ps4's mm-hmm yeah yeah I'll get kid
smooth you get it all right
face 20 BK my final super chat remember
when someone burnt the PlayStation 4
pearl on the outside of the system and
claim the pro is over I remember that
yeah I've got $5.00 shot from kid smooth
senior called Spencer and asked to use
the series X fan and heatsink on the PS
5 to fit the console from looking like a
microwave I do think you are saying that
the Microsoft shows from the start to
use a weird looking version you know
we're not used to a console looking like
that and maybe you know place they
should try to go with a more traditional
way and they saw how strong and they
didn't want to get being that
significant so maybe they tried to
overclock in that traditional way and it
didn't work you know that's all
speculation but maybe maybe that is
happening I don't know this I've got a
$5 tier trap from Bella of velvet gonna
make a game and drapes called
overclocked and see how it delay how to
delay a console laws you know got the
shout out thing you can't give them are
just something there because I bet is
funny yeah savagery ridiculous look I
get it man I think he had to jump out um
look you know this thing we don't know
we don't know what's going on um a lot
of room it's not I believe Jason
Schreyer kind of shut down a lot of this
stuff one of these guys were saying in
reference to it you know um you know I
guess maybe had a history of bad
PlayStation take so you know we'll see
but I will say I do have concerns that
from a transparency standpoint and we
haven't seen a lot from it we want to
Lowell or learn more about it and I'm
saying obviously so we just got to see
you know saying I'm not jumping out the
window yet and saying that these things
are definitely true but we definitely
need more transparency from Sony so oh I
got I do think that you know is we
obviously need new speculation but I do
think that all the weird stuffs going on
this might be what's happening like you
know we this is this is weird for Sony
to be this quiet because maybe they're
scrambling to try
to figure out this solution but you know
only time will tell you to be honest if
this is happening we might not ever know
for a fact yeah I mean these things
would never know these will be like what
you would have to come out it might be
the reason they're not showing us the
design of it because they don't know
particularly themselves Jase you try if
you ever watch it you get find out was
happy as riot in Rome he will laugh you
let us know what's going on with that
but again until you know one of those
books come out you know blood and pixels
too and we'll get the creation of the
issues with the creation of the play
stage of five we will never know so we
shall see last topic and we got to get
this quick we're gonna fly through all
the gear but all agreed that the gear
talk gearbox he you know the the
president of he I don't know if he's the
president always exact row but he
promised his all his devs you know bonus
if the game performed well did perform
well now he's trying to backtrack on
that saying that's the actual launch of
the game how much it cost to make it
made it to where they I do they still
get a little bit of a bonus just not as
big as they claimed that they would get
I'm not quite sure on that someone in
the chat definitely correct me uh if you
know and more on that information what
he said that's what he said there you
know but the problem with that is that a
lot of them take lower salaries upfront
as they're supposed to share in that
actual part and I've been told I don't
know if it's true that they sometimes
they can get up to like fifty to a
hundred thousand bonus it depends on how
good the game doesn't yeah it depends on
their their role on the game and how
well game cells and the problem with it
you know the thing is is it it's
especially bad considering the situation
in the world is and to not if if
employees you know everything that you'd
been promised to them even if
financially at the end of the day it
causes the game to get closer to the
break-even mark than you'd like I think
it was it's the right thing to do no
matter what and you know the problem is
I Randy Pitchford is constantly showed
that he when he has it when there's a
fork in the road he goes what he goes
left all the time
Oh shout to her brother Lord will me
hood 25 super check before that okay so
get the was before yeah I don't want to
skip them cuz the girl we got oh yeah we
did I'm sorry
so we got what will be hood 25 see [ __ ]
at both consoles will be great let's
hope game on did we got my make could
Drina audrey my man finality no power
plays into microsoft hands sony wasn't
really ready for that they tried out
hardware Microsoft so I guess what do
you mean as far as they weren't ready
for the power now Faisal man it's right
out hard women shout out all we're gotta
go
who got Victor Alice teen you got that
song you got that and I drank
thank you for ripping my throat about
envy our Nara for next gen will peel
five have been more powerful enough to
handle it also if Xbox series X was
clocked at two gigahertz could provide
more teraflops I think we can all agree
that the dudes a little look he's very
bad as employees I mean obviously we
don't know a hundred percent of
everything going behind there isn't he
in the company trying to publish more to
and the thing about it is if for us as a
podcast right like last year when we
went to put packs right and we saw like
we saw a different side of her yeah and
we were like and we didn't know a lot
about his past so we were enamored with
what we saw because they had a bunch of
technical difficulties in in Borderlands
tree for the first time and he was like
he was so adamant about let's get this
right because my team deserves it and it
was one of those things was I thought
okay this dude really cares about this
product he cares about his team and you
start hearing all these other things
that have been there before you know um
that we just weren't privy to so I mean
the picture that we sort of painted in
our heads of this guy from back then
this is not quite what it is
I mean maybe you know we don't know
obviously maybe if you know because I
hear they're taking they're trying to
take a little bit more of a publishing
row to you know maybe they'll get a
little bit of like the publishing stuff
from that maybe he's trying to set them
up a little bit better in the future in
the long run maybe not in the short run
I mean I don't know right now it looks
bad it does looks bad I want to shout
out to opposing sides that had big
compelling points one is obviously you
know logic struggle we had one before
you know his concern obviously is um you
know gearbox developers two counting on
that bonus you know I'm saying and now
it's substantially lowering not getting
what they you know what they really
thought they intended especially when
you look at the success of Portland's
right and it was the biggest work poor I
want to point out the man told them that
they didn't like it to quit right yeah
that the tone that was the barrier that
was about you know a lot of people did
not like that and then you know you
combine that with you know us hearing
about him having a twelve million dollar
bonus you know I'm saying you know the
the perception now to holds point who's
on the opposite side he's or the
opposite side of trial with this is like
look we don't even a I love to have both
of the brush out the hog law you know
his whole things look we don't know the
full story of this you know I'm saying
and you know if they were promised you
know saying it based on you know success
or whatever if they were told this ahead
of town and it's kind of like that's the
game plan so it's a tough woman I just
know for perception it don't feel good
it don't look good to me you know saying
that just evolved I got more Capri
what's your feeling on this situation we
get back I am I am much more let's try
to be a more on the balanced side of the
conversation when it comes to these
types of things because it is you know
it doesn't look good it is very easy to
craft a narrative of like damn the man
and there's some a lot there's a lot of
hate towards capitalism right now which
I find change because that's our I mean
yeah so I think that that's a little bit
strange there's a lot that we don't know
about like what are they doing with with
the narrative or with the with their
finances I think there's a tremendous
there's a number of reasons why and you
might not get the bonus and it's also
like this I it's hard to speak to you
because I would never work in games in
this way like I just from everything
I've heard I just never I wouldn't do it
even though I love games and you know
from from so for so many reasons I
wouldn't do it
in particular I wouldn't sign for for my
livelihood I wouldn't sign anything that
says take a take a pay cut now cuz
you'll get some later there's there's no
I'm taking that deal there's absolutely
but again like I I guess this might be
just how people do it in the business as
this is how like this is normal but like
there's no way I I want to walk away
from that as much as possible because
you don't know if this is gonna if
you're planning on if you were like I
don't know I don't like talking bad
about people the way I let's just say
for me yeah I wouldn't put like my
family in jeopardy or like put my
financial plans for my family's future
based on a thing that may or may not
happen like they're lucky that that the
game sold well that's great
but like that wasn't a guarantee mmm and
I mean really the game doesn't really
advance a lot from the other games
either so they're from our perspective
they're lucky that it did as well as it
did so that's I just want to bring a
little bit of balance to it obviously I
feel terrible that people's like
financial plans were upended especially
now like and obviously this looks
terrible before for gearbox as well and
and randy pitchford like he's a
character that we can can poke and fun
it but like why are we yet um in a chair
saying like get paid for your work
upfront it's worth what it's worth and
like the extra it just seems like the
the balance is not there right that like
the bonus should be a bonus and that the
work should is worth what it's worth
right wait so you know your main thing
is actually the the wages they they
agreed upon before you've been starting
like you should get paid for you or you
should kind of about it's like a gamble
it's like going to work and it's a it's
like a roll of the dice like hopefully
this all comes together there's stuff
with it and then the flip side to
counting is that sometimes it's just
hard to get in the industry so that you
know when these guys are presented what
a job they kind of take what they it's
exactly exactly I'm saying yeah totally
I mean we were talking about that a
little bit last week could bill still
well about that he's it's just a you
know how does this stuff continue to
happen with the crunch and everything
like that is it well you know for every
one person has a position you have 50
people waiting at the door that are
willing to do it for half that anyone in
the game and the sad part of it that is
that that's sort of a self-fulfilling
prophecy that keeps happening and yeah I
don't think the crunch thing ever goes
away and he said well for me like
honestly I'm just expensive and that's
it
I'm expensive so if you know you got to
come correct with you know with the job
and and price and that's just what it is
yeah good point good point King let's
get that get up out of here
yeah um go to this old proverb you know
a bird in hand is worth more than two of
the bush right and and insane this is um
like like sovereign said we got a chance
to see Randy in action while he's there
and he's a great performer and he works
hard for his team for what we saw right
now what was presented on the outside we
don't know what's on the inside you hear
stories about on the inside because
you're not privy to it you just see no
personal I mean outside personna the
public person I'm not the personal
persona and I always like to give a
person the benefit of the doubt until
they show you that there's no doubt what
they're doing right so what I love is
willing to look at the inside and the
outside with everyone but Sony but you
know I mean I've spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars with Sony so I'm
sorry my level of Tolerance with ABS is
not gonna happen so but but what what I
can say to this situation is this right
and it's very hard to say know your
value know your worth when there's
somebody willing to work doing your same
job on the payment so sometimes you have
to take that contract that's in front of
you and some time to to you know to feed
your family you might have to take less
with promise of the back end what I
don't respect and this is just me this
is not saying anything on a subject even
though we're talking about the subject I
don't respect somebody promising you
something on the back end and then when
that back end it's time you don't get
what is promised because right now we
didn't know that this would be happening
this carnivorous virus has gotten to a
point where it is eating the economy at
an extent that is it is tearing the
fabric of how we work how we move so
maybe that bonus would help ease
distension and they're not receiving
that relief you understand so I
for the little man at all times because
at the same time the little man will
never be able to grow into the bigger
man if he's being stifled in such a
manner and and so it's very easy to say
no your worth when you have to take
something to put food on your table and
if industry that is dog-eat-dog to be
honest with you you see it does it
somebody that knows how to program see
just like you and it's just very hard
this subject was hard for me when I
looked at it because it's very easy to
pile on the man without knowing
everything and we like I said it is
something that come out later on but um
you feel for anybody that was promised
something and they delivered but they
didn't receive what they were promised
you know and that's for the aspect that
I can take on it you know so I can
honestly say that I don't agree with
promising from one something they do the
job for you and they don't get what they
was promised right absolutely you know I
mean a completely grew King I think
you're on it you know definitely onto
something is one of situations we gotta
wait till everything comes out you know
I'm saying and you know I would say
we've heard things about gearbox in the
past that weren't too flattering
but at the same time we don't know all
the ins and outs of this situation but
that's what I got somebody Smith policy
with Gela throw it up if you can't take
a man for his word then what else is
there oh we got to get out of here do
the poll we were super long show we got
interrupted so it went even longer a new
ILP poll with the games industry gearing
up for more software delays similar to
last of us minecraft dungeons wasting
etc due to the virus pandemic how do we
feel Microsoft should handle halos
infinite launch alongside series X if
only the physical release is not 100%
ready the choices are a halo infinite is
too important for serious series X
launch launch launch that digital be
separate campaign for multiplayer launch
campaign only physical release see
completely delay halo infinite until it
your game is ready ordy I don't care and
less grounded or Battletoads launched
before halo infant please Rock the Vote
when he goes up with IL peach at a Super
Bowl show but we got to salute lower
Shore Capri for rockin out with us the
entire time I feel so good
geez Oh wicked five people talk I'll
find you what you got going on sir and
thanks again man for rocking out with us
please thank you for having me man this
was awesome we got a little bit of the
Sony talk a little place the Xbox it was
so much fun man thank you guys so much
for the invite you can find me on
Twitter it's Sean like Connery Capri
like the pants and please follow if you
guys like Xbox from the Xbox Drive is a
podcast I like doing very very much yes
if you like Nintendo a cup of joe
Nintendo these are these are short shows
these are half an hour shows that you'd
better bite-size like two months and
then yeah we the gamer cast as well as a
one on one kind of get to know one
another type of show a shows comes out
on Mondays on all of the podcast so I
just really appreciate you guys
welcoming in here and the chat was
amazing and so much fun so thank you
guys so much thank you for having thanks
for rocket again salute to you because
again I love the positivity you bring
the community I love your infectious
humor the energy you bring you do a lot
for the committee and again through you
and your content
I just got a beat a cool another subset
of people gonna say that all all cool
they all know each other so it was great
to have you in the room will definitely
bring you back you gotta have look Capri
like the pants I like that she was good
on the on Twitter
Lord Alex I'll be I wanted first of all
want to thank our guests for coming on
the show uses definitely great guests
you know it's a good guest when the show
goes on really too long yes as we end up
getting uh you know I might fight with
the Lord's man but I love I love these
men you know they're uh they they're my
they're my family with a little darker
complexion
I want to thank everyone for coming up
here definitely that like button if you
don't mind hit that Bell icon you know
cuz if YouTube sometimes likes messing
up in a you know maybe toys sometimes
that'll help you get to our show every
Sunday at 1:00 p.m. and definitely you
know when he puts statues up in his uh
yes you know there's a great statue in
his car back tall so you definitely want
to catch it into this know that salute
that even graphic got like short capris
fellow Canadian happy to be introduced
he followed you everywhere look a man
thanks so much that's awesome no Lord
soft powering through low twice and
still trying to push it but he beat her
rip we're gonna bother you guys catch me
on Twitter Lourdes happy and be
excellent on PSN and Xbox Live and
hopefully uh getting some doom in trying
to get past the dude doing was crazy man
you know way well you know if yeah I
know Oh Frankie you're gonna be
surprised and big shout out to look the
prefect appreciate thank you salut salut
and of course by far the messiest
version of King I have ever seen for the
three-time extreme can't the lord of
mess wallowing in the pain of Sony
favorites everywhere way to the five
people find first of all I want to shout
out to Sean Lowe John Capri oh you have
made this a memorable dig this man no
sorry affected you carnivorous something
the tea with me it was truly amazing
your history everything your wonderful
relationship everything everything is
beautiful it was a great day I swear I
mean I really had a blast in history was
amazing catch me at uh Lord King no King
David OTW on Twitter please get all mods
with a if your Sony
when you were in the shadow you would
listen and you really think you have
more time of your day to give more Sony
fans on Twitter at King David ot do you
like sticks amazing gifts he uses over
and over again a clown on yo-yo I want
all the smoke you see in just like game
pass if you never seen those gifts they
new gifts for you you know not having
any combat talk later but now because
stuff that's going on but also um king
of statues I have a great statue that's
coming up that rivals just statue by
every measure of the word I mean if you
thought that this statue remotely
tickled your fancy pause the next one is
definitely gonna send me through the
roof please go to Lords of gaming net
way to see older episodes of iron Lords
podcast and also king of the statues and
please do me a favor man I would like
you guys to check out the last word with
low Cognito and democritus on what the
card said I was just tired but I need to
watch it the race yeah I do that a lot I
catch up on a lot of people podcasters
you know like when I'm laying in bed you
know to catch up with everybody stuff
because I do really love the content
that's out here you guys are poppin so I
got a new content or podcast to listen
to because this dish drive sounds
incredible to me and if no I could do a
half now late
you already know better salute already
know and again yet thank you again
welcome people coming through again it
was fantastic chat was amazed Lou to the
chat again and wanna reiterate you know
the notification gang especially thank
you all all for hitting that obviously
have our issues with it so again if you
were in here and you're subscribe please
make sure you click that Bell button hit
all make sure you don't miss the show so
that if you know Google has the issues
again as we've had issues again you're
gonna say that we would go through a but
I'll be a fantastic show please support
Lords of gaming dotnet all the articles
are there all the writers has been
fantastic and I'm gonna save my brother
he bothers cuz he says I don't say no I
ope the best SP podcast she ever heard
all Fridays the last word or kognito
bosses will be always going at him and
for showing why he's wrong he's always
exposing me while I brought that was out
of control as we said you know I don't
know they come for me baby brings other
Titan guest on to show a jump me T to
oil type evil stuff
it gives me with that about somewhat
lower law brings all type of Titan
fanboys in there Nene dude a foolishness
but that's salute please I love the
support we see some growth there really
means a lot to us and again salute to
solve everybody look enjoy your Sunday
I'm gonna give you out his cool outro to
go to and we will see you next week
fees
[Music]
[Music]